ça peut être un point de fragilité ça
pour alexandre macron pour avec malaga
est 7e cette impuissance dont parlait
lucile schmid et que le prison un public
reconnaît quasiment c'est ce que les
français vont pas lui reprocher bien sûr
que si elle lui reprocheront parce que
les chiffres lui donnerons pas raison il
n'y arrivera pas vous l'avez vous l'avez
très bien dit là encore on est sur une
dérive historique c'est à dire que on a
on a conçu des dispositifs à une époque
où le monde n'était pas devenu ce qu'il
est devenu
et on a été très très généreux d'une
certaine façon et c'est sans doute très
bien d'être très généreux avec cette
idée de pouvoir ouvrir deux pour
accueillir et on a même fait sauter en
je crois en descendent 2012 le fait que
le séjour illégal et été n'est plus un
délit
donc on peut rentrer ça c'est un délit
se faire prendre au moment où on passe
la frontière c'est un délit mais
finalement séjourner en france de
manière illégale c'est plus un délit
donc automatiquement ça vous oblige ça
vous amène pas sortir du pays
bon est ce que c'est bien ce que c'est
bien moralement on peut se poser la
question mais moralement c'est pas mal
d'accueillir sauf qu'entre temps il ya
eu toute une série de crises y compris
provoquée par la france la libye on a
fait sauter le verrou libyen a donc de
fait on a ouvert la méditerranée et et
de fait on a plein de deux malheureux
qui arrivent chez nous la guerre en
syrie n'a échappé à personne et ça ça
provoque des flux migratoires
considérable et on a des dispositifs qui
ont été conçus à une époque où on n'a
pas imaginé tout ça donc on a un
anachronisme juridiques techniques
légales qui est très compliqué et un
système qui s'appelle l'état de droit
qui nous enferment au nom de l'état de
droit un moment donné on peut pas faire
n'importe quoi et d'ailleurs ont fait
pas n'importe quoi parce qu'on est un
état de droit qui se veut respectueuse
sinon c'est plus un état de droit ça
s'appelle la russie par exemple pour
dire un gros vent en tout cas ça
s'appelle plus l'état droits tels que
nous on a conçu avec des vraies valeurs
et ça pose un vrai sujet maintenant
comment on fait dans la durée c'est
forcément compliqué parce qu'on ne peut
pas continuer à amalgamer sous prétexte
qu'il ya des migrations
tout le monde en pensant que ça va bien
se passer ça ne se passera pas bien dans
la durée si on n'est pas très attentifs
donc il ya un énorme sujets de fond est
par contre prendre des engagements aussi
précis que ce qu'il a fait hier pour le
coup c'est effectivement un risque un
peu vous parliez de 10 à 30 ans il faut
être un peu démago là il a été un peu de
mal